what a great first game it was 14
carries 107 rush yards two rushing
touchdowns that's the way to start with
a new team as Mark Ingram is back here
on the Rich Eisen show how are you mark
I'm good how are you damn straight
you're good I mean was how did this even
surprise you this offensive output on
Sunday man we knew we were trying to be
explosive we know we have playmakers all
over the field you know you know we
believe that we were able to do this
type of thing but just be able to go out
there and execute it offense defense of
special teams you know it was huge for
us confidence builder and we just got to
keep improving keep getting better and
hopefully we can keep that output dog
absolutely so why is Lamar Jackson so
good mark walk me through do you you you
got to see him up close now I'm assuming
you voted for him for the Heisman hey
yeah he's just a special player man he
has a special mindset he has the
athletic and physical tools arm strength
obviously a special talent running the
ball the proper mindset the proper
demeanor composure in the huddle
leadership abilities and man he just has
everything you need for a great
quarterback for a great player for a
great leader and just being around him
and he's a gamer man when the lights
come on he shines so he has everything
you need to be successful it's up to us
to help him make his job easier and help
him have mo successes he possibly can
and are there any comparisons between
him and Brees I'm serious I'm not I'm
not just throwing that around but you've
been in a huddle with a with a goat and
now you're with it with a young
up-and-comer right now do you see any
similarities whatsoever mark I think the
only similarities is the desire to be
great the desire to want to be the best
I think those are the most similar
similarities that they have they're
completely different players completely
different people but the desire to be
great the desire to want to be the best
I think that's where they have
similarities Mark Ingram Ravens running
back here on the Rich Eisen show what
can be improved based off of what we
just saw everything can be improved
obviously when you score 59 points and
you have a record day from numerous guys
to top that but I think there was lots
of things that we could clean up on the
film just small technique things small
things that we'll have to get corrected
so it doesn't hurt us when we're in
close games and when we're going against
great teams on the road
there's our small things that we need to
execute and continue to improve on to
make sure those small things don't hurt
us when the game's on the line and the
games are important what about you mark
I mean going to Baltimore did that sting
leaving New Orleans I mean what will
walk me through the process of leaving
the only professional spot you've known
to find a new home um I know it was a
possibility going into free agency that
I might not be in the world as anymore
it's just it's just it's just a business
man it really is um you know I was
waiting just to see my value on the
market and you know the Saints made a
move in silence Avis Murray and at that
point I pretty much knew that I'd be
going to another place so the main goal
initially was to stay in New Orleans but
it didn't end up working out that way
and it worked out the way as opposed to
I'm in a great place here in Baltimore
the organization one of me and I wanted
to be here and there I'm just trying to
be a part of something special here in
the Ravens locker room yeah I mean it is
and it is a special place I mean your
did you ever play a game in Baltimore is
this gonna be your first one actually we
played in Baltimore last year and Saints
came to Baltimore I'm coming one thanks
to a missed extra point yeah but um so I
know the atmosphere is a great
atmosphere I know the fans are loud and
uh the team plays physical so I'm
excited about my first game and
Baltimore as a raven so Mark Ingram do
you hear it does it get in the locker
room cuz I think it does
I heard Lamar say not bad for a running
back when when he stepped off the field
and most met the Mike's on Sunday do you
guys hear all the stuff that this
offense is not sustainable and that
Jackson isn't a so-called elite or real
quarterback we we we hear it we've been
hearing it we've been hearing the
chatter we're here to talk how do we pay
attention to it know do we care about it
know we believe in each other we believe
in Lamar we
even our team so I think that's all that
matters and obviously after the output
you know some people are trying to you
know pump us up and we're not drinking
that tea man we're staying home we're
staying hungry and we're staying trying
to get better every day
what about those who are pumping you up
well before those games those people we
appreciate you and we are trying to
prove you right we're trying to prove
you correct y'all can stay on the train
you know you're taught us to hop off but
all the Bissell believes can stay on the
track you know you're specifically just
talking to me I'm the only one I think I
think I won't you be my do say day one
that's why you might got you know I mean
that's why you're my guy you know what
you're talking about a and you have
faith man so I appreciate you know I
plus you know obviously I'm partial to
Harbaugh's as you know mark what what is
it what is your exposure to John and the
system there Ben could you tell me a
good story where you knew you were in
the right spot man the way he talks the
way he communicates the way he wants his
teams to play football games the
attention to detail of how to win a
football game it's not just no it's not
just one of the whig Anderson there's no
how to win a football game situational
football smart football being physical
being explosive being smart and just all
the things he talks about how he once
attained to be high he wants his players
to be I just knew I was in the right
place and so it's been Pleasant ever
since my first time me and my family
landed in Baltimore it's been love and
if I couldn't be in the ones I'm glad
I'm here in Baltimore and I could
definitely could see myself being a
raver for a long time and Hollywood
Brown what what do you think he can do
after that I mean that was amazing
you've been around some very talented
receivers where does he rank mark man
obviously it was his first game in for
you to go for four catches for 147 in
two TDs first two touches go for
touchdown I don't know if I've been
around a receiver that had done that but
um I think he just has to keep improving
keep building his confidence and um
sky's the limit for him and he has the
right running abilities he has
electrifying play making ability when
you get the ball in his hands and he has
a special instinct for tracking the deep
ball so just good hands speed a loose
this I think he's everything you look
for in explosive playmaker in his League
well his college quarterbacks coming to
town mark he's coming to town uh-huh and
so I asked this question and I you
always shoot me straight and I know I
might be putting you on the spot did you
vote for Kyler Murray for the Heisman
last year no I he was on my ballot but
you know you know I'm Velma Velma so you
just read that how you want to know you
reading today how you want to but he
definitely deserved it and he was on my
ballot but you know we have a special
bammel quarterback over here and I was
played by the half the season
you know he was out you know for you
know the second half majority of eight
games last year so I think we got
special quarterback in Tuscaloosa too
yeah I know that I know that mark and in
that regard so many people believe Miami
covets him as well to the point that
they are tanking did you feel that you
were playing against a tanking team on
Sunday I didn't get that feeling um the
league is tough man and they have good
players you know it was just one of
those days where we were on we were
physical from the first snap and we was
able to get a big win man I didn't feel
like those guys are tanking I feel like
they're gamer effort but you know it's a
tough situation over there but uh I know
they got some guys that are trying to
you know get them out of it well I guess
then that that's an unfair question
because I personally don't believe the
players are purposely trying to lose I
think the front office is set up a
situation that makes it difficult for
the players that are there to win and
I'm wondering if you might have sensed
towards a certain part of the game that
the opponents were feeling that I guess
that's a better way to put it mark man
honestly I felt like they were putting
an effort I didn't think they were
tanking I didn't like they were you know
going through the motions but like you
said I think there's a lot of more in a
tough situation and when the game
obviously isn't going your way
it's obviously you can let that the
circumstances and what's going on within
the organization overcome you I guess
I don't know but I felt like their
giving effort and you know they have a
lot of good players on their team but I
think we just had a great game as you
know everyone's sure so are you gonna
you an are g3 and Lamar and Kyler gonna
take like a Heisman pose photograph at
some point before or after the game I'm
not missing anybody am i that's that's
not yeah I think that's I think those
were the four that'll be on the field on
Sunday and it would be nice to get a
picture with everybody you know I
wouldn't mind that at all
you're the you're the you're the og in
that picture mark correct yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I started with Nate I was tall
on when they trophy Oh couple years ago
so then I'll ask you again I'll put you
on the spot again did you vote for all
of them they were all on my ballot for
three on all of them no they were all on
my belly I know okay no cuz you're
second and third and fourth you're smart
guy okay I can't tell you the order of
my balance I just tell you they were on
my bad guys they were eligible for your
votes boys okay they got points from
from my boat you don't me each one two
three holds a quality amount of points
they all got some points from okay how
often do you speak to save him was the
last time you spoke to him Oh last time
I spoke to Coach Saban was prob about
two months ago okay yeah about two
months ago one of those conversations
like man I was in Tuscaloosa and we just
caught up and no talking about the team
talking about me being in Baltimore and
just catching up really nothing too
crazy just catching up with each other
you gotta tell me something about him I
don't know before I let you go gimme
give me a good story from you and Saban
and because he has such you know he has
obviously such a reputation of being a
bit of a you know hard-ass yeah but give
me something about saving that I mean I
hear mom Dan Patrick show all the time
and he said that his wife once told him
he's got to lighten up and interviews
and things like that but give me give me
a good one
Sabre so man my coach Manuel you know
expect you know inspectors from him but
man he tried to quit on me one time man
what do you is in a golf tournament did
a little chick-fil-a golf tournament and
you know we're in a playoff and in the
last hole 18 we had two we're in a
playoff we played the hole like three
times with verse two other groups and we
kept time we kept time we kept time we
were driving back to the tee box he like
man if we tie again he's i'ma have to
probably get out of here I got somewhere
to be
I got a plane to catch I'm like coach
man late we in a playoff me about to win
this whole tournament man you talking
like you trying to go he's like you're a
teach me that you know I don't know what
you get that from but anyways we we teed
off on the last hole and we ended up
losing that playoff and I told them I
said you brought us that negative energy
man you wanted he was talking about if
we tied again that she was gonna have to
leave catch the fly leave early and you
know we ended up losing on that on that
uh playoff hole how did take that you
basically accused him of bringing rat
poison into the syrup here hey he
remembers he knows I'm sure he'll tell
you the same story he'll justify my
story
um I checked him and I think that kind
of opened his eyes to know that you know
you got to be accountable man I held him
accountable as he's held me accountable
sometimes you're the best man
hey Mark congrats on that big first
start here in Baltimore I'm I cannot
wait to see what unfolds from here on
out for your team you know I'm very high
on the prospects for your squad
appreciate appreciate you risk a to
support man always okay Mark Ingram does
Mark you're following me on Twitter
right we've been through this before
of course okay we're Twitter friends we
are my BFF Mark Ingram good to chat
thanks take care of it right back at you
at Mark Ingram
21 for more of the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app